they signed that they swore in on the
Korean oh we have the Bible we're going
to talk about swearing in on the how to
swear in on the Bible with them and let
them know what our law says that you
can't swear in on the Koran so we're
gonna we're gonna explain to that you
know we're going to explain about how
you can't swear in on the Koran and
we're going to have the Bible and ask
them if they would swear in on the Bible
that we really need them yeah we have
the oath yep
this is
stunning Krueger in in rare rare form
so certain of herself that it was
against the law at some point
to use anything other than the Holy
Bible to swear on members of Congress
were swearing on Spider-Man comic books
or Superman comic books this Congress
you can swear on anything
if I were a member of Congress I think
I'd probably put my hand upon the
Constitution of the United States